benjamin castaldi mon petit fils ou à la
la la la il part de loin
benjamin castaldi il a des yeux petite
île à
une allocution
peu convaincante
il a des oignons aux pieds
c'est l'homme à la plus grosse poitrine
et pourtant il est encore là chaque jour
on se dit bâton le m
tu peux la question qu'on se pose avec
vous daniel
[Rires]
et chaque jour on le met contraire de
vous
c'est à combien de saison septième
septième saison ouais tu sais la télé
c'est comme l'amour ah oui la télé ne
dure que c'est en a c'est peut-être le
moment de partir vers d'autres horizons
mais non
mais d'abord récap castaldi aller
[Musique]
lacasse a dit moi j'ai une question êtes
vous content de votre opération des
questions
d'hier et d'être utilisé
c'est quoi cette photo
son petit corps c'est la seule chance
mais aujourd'hui il a des faux seins il
annonce
cet accord croisé spectacle
[Musique]
pour le court parce que tant à dire miam
ça manque de profondeur on ne comprend
rien à ce qu'ils disent et là ça n'a
aucun intérêt
la française des jeux a compris tu as
dis mais pourquoi ce monsieur pourquoi
ce qu'on joue là nos combinaisons qui
est tombée la semaine dernière ils se
sont dits oui ça m'est arrivé aussi
[Musique]
ce type est peut-être un véritable
émoi suffisants aient pu la merde c'est
tout la part des choses et tu me
commence à faire chier je te le dis et
le contre d'un bouffon mais vous avez la
logorrhée détachées situées il m'a
raccroché au nez lors de la dernière
convention
six ans
merci madame à aller je vous ai fait là
s'appelle insulter les gens plus
publiquement moi et mon père traiter sa
mère depuis tout ça ça je vous dis
franchement ça ne se fait pas monsieur
couverture à des sorts de seconde
vous allez arrêter de poids de penser
que dans nos socios c'est un des
meilleurs soir à maire de paris qu'on
peut tous d'univers si je vous avant la
loi monsieur votre fille jouer l'armée
serbe je suis pas mon fils c'est ce qui
nous fait chier
qu'il appelle son émission vitamine c
moi je dis je lui conseille de la nappe
les thermomètres au moins sur la m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
benjamin castaldi
c'est son conseil de classe
car comme vous le savez il reste
maintenant huit émissions voilà donc
juin
on va démarrer pas
ballerini a donc commencé par tout ce
qui est gentillesse benjamin tu es mon
chéri un excellent camarade tu es gentil
est toujours partant pour l'adar cas on
l'a vu ça un incroyable second degré
étaient prêts à toutes les conneries à
te déguiser et des contenants de faire
quelque chose tu y vas ça c'est sûr et
certain mais
problème cette année bungie tu sais pas
ce qui s'est passé ce qui n'était pas le
cas l'année dernière tu es un peu absent
dans les débats tu n'es pas là alors il
ya deux possibilités soit c'est parce
que t'es trop bien élevé et ça non je
n'y crois pas et quand on te donne la
parole soit c'est parce que tu somme
donne entre deux paix et ça je pense
quand c'est
donc il est temps que tu te réveilles et
quand tu te réveilles parfois on l'a
bien vu malheureusement n'est pas
forcément tout à fait compréhensible
parce que tu as une diction qui n'est
pas extraordinaire et je parle même pas
de parent est parti néanmoins mon chéri
mais on tue est essentielle à l'émission
je relève excusez-moi exclure alors
julien ce qu'ils m'ont dit tu es sans
aide des maisons anciennes et n'est pas
dire si son chef salou pas intéressé
mais ces dix mois pour moi et
l'essentiel avec avoue par contre
[Rires]
je suis
cyril tué essentiel l émission et pour
toutes ces raisons je te donne 1,6 vers
si
on va enchaîner avec daniel moreau ont
fait daniel way alors dans l'est
[Musique]
[Rires]
tu as tellement l'anecdote on a
l'impression que tu as eu mille vies
mais tu as 0 répartie et reid a un petit
peu dit dont tu m'as mis plus de râteaux
que nicolas le jardinier énorme moi
évidemment parce que c'est pas faute de
t'avoir demandé mais plus je ne voit
toujours rien venir dans l'est plus
c'est vrai que tu es très bon camarade
et tu es très simple parce que tu as été
une énorme star et c'est toujours une
stable donc effectivement dire il a été
nommé c'est vrai mais quand une star tu
les fais toujours voilà mais il se prend
pas pour une star donc vous connaissez
cette expression il ne pète pas plus
haut que son derrière mouvement benjamin
peste à la hauteur de son derrière donc
ça sort et on en profite donc ça c'est
ton grand grand - et je tenais donc à 7
voilà oui vous m'appellerez de plus
faire les conseils de classe à gagner
si vous êtes gentils les aiguille j'ai
dit aux équipes pour qu'on soit sûr
prochaine voir jean basile magie alors
mon benji moi j'ai une tendresse et une
affection toute particulière pour toi
parce qu'on est arrivé en même temps il
ya sept ans dans l'aventuré pmp montre
un truc qui nous lit comme une sorte de
millésimes et ça ça restera entre toi et
moi comme un truc particulier notre cas
là qui sont partis et nous on est restés
et on a été courageux
et voilà alors le premier truc d'abord
point fort effectivement valérie l'a dit
un super bon camarade tu es drôle
tesfran t loyal t cachant des ruines et
mettez cash
ensuite le deuxième truc que j'aime
beaucoup chez toi c'est qu'en fait tu es
le seul à seul personne autour de la
table avoir à être une star zouzaf et
avoir été aussi riche en millions tu
vois et j'aime comment tu nous parles de
ta vie de thé déboires de thé addiction
aïe plus du cul
toutes les montagnes russes sont
qu'autant parle absolument avec beaucoup
d'autodérision beaucoup d'humilité et
moi personnellement en tant que
téléspectatrice et chroniqueuse je
trouve ça vachement intéressant est
vachement émouvant alors ensuite il ya
un vrai problème en revanche c'est qu'il
faut arrêter au brigitte bardot de
pattaya la reine des neiges la boxer
avec des boxeurs avec des seins jeu là
où il est le meilleur c'est là je crois
c'est là où il est le meilleur non
écoute que moi là dessus non mais ils
sont pas donnés leur avis là-dessus la
manivelle mais alors pleurer les enfants
comme ça
moi je déciderai les chansons qui font
pleurer les enfants tavini ce méchant tu
fais pleurer les mômes je te mets 4 aux
traits machine
[Applaudissements]
allez on va maintenant à bernard montiel
qui est là ça non si si qu'est ce qui
t'arrive pas de quoi non mais rien volé
j'ai dit quelque chose sur lui non ça je
vais vous dire il n'y a aucune répartie
notre ami a annoncé avant comprend rien
ce qui dit il dort beaucoup dans
l'émission ce qui est pratique parce
quand il ouvre il fait chier
je trouve bon je trouve donc on va
concourir à dessus parce que moi je
serai producteur il aurait dégagé depuis
longtemps
j'avais 4
mondiale au mali les jours qui s'est dit
les choses êtes vous voyez dans la
bouche année tandis que tu vas bien
né c'est super bon gars bah oui donc
c'est un super bon gars pour être à la
maison pour y chercher des trucs mais si
j'ai bien compris ton petit message oui
moi j'aime bien marin parce qu'il est
gentil ça c'est pour le positif
pour le négatif gens parler encore et
cyril hier de jour en jour tu deviens ce
qu'on appelle un ignoble bof
vous savez au téléphone c'est ce genre
d'épreuve une dernière social au
restaurant avec kelly lorsqu'il est
arrivé benjamin a demandé au directeur
de mettre le générique de secretstory de
se faire annoncer au micro
de foot et
kelis pas vrai arrêté
à
l'aller et ça c'est aussi vrai il n'a eu
de cesse de lâcher d'immondes caisse
dans le reste à tel point que les
saveurs été contraint de remettre un
masque ffp2
grâce aux saisies 3 ressaisis toi j'aime
bien 3 voilà c'est comme ça dépote
[Rires]
je t'ai dit
alors moi tu me connais benjamin je suis
beaucoup trop dans les sentiments pour
voir te mettre une note parce que moi tu
étais le grand frère que j'ai choisi on
se soutient dans les bons et les mauvais
moments tu as toujours été là pour moi
depuis des années maintenant et ça ne
fait que s'accroître donc au final je me
suis dis pas que je pouvais pas te
mettre de notes mais comme je suis
obligé par notre chef je t'ai mis note
que j'ai choisi vis-à-vis de tas de ta
vie que je connais par coeur donc je
t'ai mis 4 comme thé mariage l'année
prochaine je te mettrai sûrement 5
le bush
allait il nous reste gilles verdez
raymond à et géraldine
la gym et raymond omba dernier
c'est le prof le plus sévère vraiment
non moi benjamin j'adore c'est alors
qu'à peine de démarrer et efface par non
mais il attendait mars et pas par non
mais moi j'adore
j'adore ce que c'est le grand frère on
se parle beaucoup en texte on se parle
beaucoup au téléphone il me donne des
conseils il m'a donné tout le temps des
conseils sur la télé on se classent
souvent si les appareils et n'a
pas écouté
si la panique fermer ta gueule des fois
ça rigolait parce que je le connais
qu'est ce qui t'a donné comme conseil
non il raccroche
c'est une folle conseils qu'il donne non
non non non moi j'adore j'adore parce
que ça c'est un coma un mec qui me
soutient ici comme beaucoup d'autres
mais il fait des moitiés de tout des
moitiés d'intervention et moitié de
phrases c'est jean michel aphatie la
moitié des yeux mais jean-michel après
la moitié des yeux une jambe dès fois la
moitié d'une jambe donc c'est pour ça
que je vais te mettre la moitié jeu de
médecins
vous pouvez les benjamin castaldi nous
rappelle pierre sondage 1 vous avez qui
est fait par mon ami damien mercereau
sur
tvmag et je vous dis je vous dirai qui a
gagné prochainement à la fin des
conseils de classe je vous dirais qu'il
a gagné son match ya déjà eu plus de
quinze mille votants gilbert des
benjamins
fait une très belle saison
alors évidemment si on oublie vos
dizaine d'interventions sans aucun
intérêt aux enquêtes bâclées et vos
propos inaudibles dès que vous ouvrez la
bouche mais franchement je vous ai
trouvé nettement moins mauvais que
toutes les saisons précédentes où vous
étiez nul
vous êtes de benjamin c'est quand vous
garder le silence you fermé refait ses
seins proéminents
fermez vos gueules essaiera bien mieux
javaux j'avoue c'est ma faiblesse vous
êtes mon ami donc j'ai mis une autre
très généreuse vous aimez
est-ce qu'on a la note
des téléspectateurs s'il vous plaît est
ce qu'on l'a ou pas les notes la note
des téléspectateurs ou est ce qu'on l'a
pas demandé je vais aussi nordine voilà
ça arrive à quelle heure 18 note écrite
hausse à 3 points 9 sur 10 autant dire
que vous faites
un sur dix c'est votre moyenne moyen n'a
pas trop de sens du mot alors saison de
benjamin est une chose à dire
un très gentil à trop gentil bah alors
je vais je ne peux pas
non non je vais vous dire la vérité
benjamin cadet là c'est mon amant déjà
c'est mon ami et pour moi il est autant
inutiles qu'indispensables dans
l'émission non mais c'est vrai gentil
il est vraiment indispensable dans
l'émission une émission au chômage
demain castaldi c'est pas la même mais
parce que déjà c'est vrai que c'est mon
un petit peu mon binôme c'est une
référence de la vanne opa 2 il rassure
c'est benjamin castaldi s'est pas voilà
auparavant qu'elle
est il est vachement il est une
autodérision regard c'est vraiment et je
l'adoré pour ça et c'est vrai que quand
on comprend ce qu'il dit il a souvent
des bonnes analyses très après voilà il
faut comprendre
c'était quand sa dernière bonne analyse
alors il a toujours des bonnes analyses
malheureusement c'est vrai qu'il faut
avoir le décodeur alors je suis pas
encore abonné j'espère que je reprenais
l'année prochaine mais en tout cas pour
moi il fait une très belle saison cette
année et c'est vrai que c'est toujours
les qu'il est toujours là pour se
déguiser mal rigolé pour déconner pour
prendre du chocolat dans la gueule ce
même si on s'y attend pas voilà pour
même pour divorcer
c'est vrai que c'est important voilà
c'est quelqu'un qui pourrait même
divorcé pour le bien des missions donc
bravo benjamin pour tout ce que tu fais
et franchement moi tu seras toujours mon
amour quoi qu'il arrive est mon ami mais
plutôt un employé et un ami sa place
elle est à mes côtés sur le plateau que
j'ai besoin d'un ami ce plateau comme
j'en ai pas d'autre non je rigole
non mais c'est vrai et benjamin moi je
trouve qu'il fait une très belle saison
13e trou vous avez ternel comme sévère
avec lui mais je trouve qu'il a été très
très vieux et le vendredi il fait de
très bons scores également quoi qui me
remplace donc bravo mons belgique amour
[Applaudissements]